en varios de los vídeos pasados hemos
hablado de derivadas y de cómo aplicar
el operador derivada por ejemplo si
nosotros calculamos la derivada con
respecto a x de x cuadrada entonces
vamos a obtener de resultado 2x si
nosotros aplicamos el operador derivada
a la función x cuadrada más 1 pues el
resultado también me daba 2x y si
nosotros aplicamos el operador derivada
con respecto a x de la función x
cuadrada más pi también nos da de
resultado 2x porque la derivada de x
cuadrada es 2x y la derivada de una
constante con respecto a x es 0 la
derivada de 1 es una constante por lo
tanto 0 y por lo tanto el resultado de
esta derivada es 2x y más aún la
derivada con respecto a x de cualquier
función que sea de la forma x cuadrada
más una constante va a ser 2x porque la
derivada de x cuadrada es 2x y recuerden
que la derivada de cualquier constante
con respecto a x es 0 por lo tanto se
cancelarían y date cuenta que en esta
ocasión cuando aplicamos el operador
derivada a cualquiera de estas
expresiones medio de resultado 2x ahora
lo que quiero es que lo veamos desde
otra perspectiva en este vídeo vamos a
hablar acerca de la anti derivada la
anti derivada va a ser nuestro tema de
conversación y qué es la anti derivada
pues va a ser lo contrario a la derivada
es decir en la derivada nosotros
calculamos la derivada de x cuadrada en
medio 2 x en esta ocasión lo que yo me
quiero preguntar es cuál es la anti
derivada de 2x lo podemos pensar como
que funciona al derivar la me daría 2x
es decir lo que queremos decir no sean
reversa
nosotros vamos a darle a este nuevo
operador 2x y quiero que me regrese algo
para que sea más entendible lo podemos
seguir pensando de esta manera cuál es
la función la cual al derivar la nos va
a dar 2x o dicho de otra manera que
funciona al derivar la nos da de
resultado 2x pues rápidamente tú me
podrías dar la respuesta de decirme es x
cuadrada la función que al derivar la
medida 12 x x cuadrada sin embargo
también x cuadrado más 1 la función que
al derivar la medida 2x también sé que
es cuadrada más 1 y también lo es x
cuadrada más pim
podríamos generalizar lo diciendo que la
función que al derivar la humedad 2 x x
cuadrada más una constante y es justo
está la anti derivada porque si nosotros
derivamos x cuadrada más c me va a dar
2x esto es lo que yo pienso cuando hablo
de anti derivadas y sé que esta pregunta
parece ser un poco ambigua pero antes de
ver porque lo que quiero es ver un poco
de notación a la anti derivada se le
pone un símbolo y ese símbolo es este de
aquí como una s larga y al final se le
pone un de equis viendo en este caso
particular tendremos esta expresión la
integral de 2x de x es igual a lo que ya
calculamos es decir x cuadrada más una
constante la anti derivada de 2x de x es
x cuadrada más una constante y si tú te
preguntas por qué usamos esta anotación
creo que la respuesta a esa pregunta
está pensado en una idea de sumas es
decir en el área bajo la curva y hay
vídeos acerca de ello pero bueno lo que
sí te quiero contar y lo que es
importante es que esta expresión que yo
tengo aquí que voy a señalar ahorita se
le conoce como integral indefinida que
en este caso particular se diría algo
así la integral indefinida de 2x es
igual a x cuadrada más en la integral
indefinida de 2x que al final es lo
mismo que decir que tomar la anti
derivada de 2x